how you doing today sir dude I wanted to
sit down with you for uh years listen
you've had a restraining order against
me and uh I as soon as it lifted I said
let's do this interview it happened to
co coincide with a new show you have
coming out so it all worked out yeah and
you know through this process of there's
restraining order you really you know
you blew up and listen you're you're
like the Barbara Walters of the geek
world not even the geek world now it's
just the pop culture you're the bar
Walter of Pop Culture I I don't
necessarily think that way but I will
say that I have been very very lucky the
last number of years and I'm very
grateful to everyone that reads collider
and tunes into our stuff I really am
yeah all right let's jump into you
because we're not here to talk about me
uh you've done a lot of cool stuff if
someone has never seen anything you've
made before it's the first thing you
want them watching and why Captain
laserhawk uh it is the amalgamation of
everything that's come before it it's
all the learning of
the 14 plus years have
been running around this business in a
Netflix series I have first of all let
me start by saying how much I enjoyed
the series it's six episodes start
streaming on Netflix soon I have a
million questions about that but I still
have more curveballs to throw your away
um if you can get the financing to make
anything you want like the dream thing
what is it do you know that project yeah
yeah I mean look I think there's two
categories of things right one is
original stuff because I would say
captain laser Hawk and and you tell me
if I'm if I'm wrong here because
you're you're Frosty but uh Captain
laserhawk is original it's like an
original thing right and then something
like Devil May Cry something like
castlemania that's IP based right but
it's it's a
reinterpretation of of the IP so I I
literally have original scripts just
sitting around that I'm I'm that I've
developed and uh you know kept in my
back pocket for the next moment I have a
heat and I'm like blowing up and I can
be like bam here you go two seasons done
let's go so you have that thing you're
just waiting to yeah yeah I have
actually three of them it's like three
different things that are just that I
poured years into meticulously [__]
sculpting like this these these
different universes is the bootleg
Universe over because you know what I
mean like the beginning there you did
some
things and I'm just curious if if if
that chapter of your life is over
because you sort of entered a more
mainstream area no no no it's not
because I feel like there's a rebellious
nature to these the fan films and when
you say the bootleg Universe you mean
the fan films right these unauthorized
fan films that got a reaction sure
people right I'm not going to
stop rebelling right but I think as you
grow older and you discover yourself
more and you get more in touch with your
Soul's Journey um maybe the expression
of it changes well you also managed with
like Captain laserhawk and um you've
managed to put in things that are not
expected like I was not expecting things
that happen in Captain laserhawk and the
way you do certain things on that show
so maybe like the like the the DNA of
the bootleg Universe beginning is in the
shows you're making 100% I mean Captain
laserhawk is part of the bootleg
Universe right it is it is the natural
uh extension it is The Logical extension
of where you go with these subversive
fan films that are deconstructionist
takes on IPS That Grew Up Loving like
ultimately that is what that is 50% of
what Captain laser Ro is uh were you
surprised Castlevania uh ran for four
seasons on Netflix it got incredible
reviews were you surprised at the the
level of the reviews you got for the
show
no no because at the time it was
so
different and uh and I feel like the way
video games video game
adaptations uh intellectual property was
being approached was always like in one
box and then Castlevania was doing these
other things and I'm like okay I I know
this is going to work right I was
surprised as as to how mainstream it
became sure was it always designed as a
Four Season show well you know there's
there is a fifth season well there's a
there's like a spin-off thing now going
on am I wrong about this but that's I
mean how do you define a spin-off versus
a derivative versus a like there's also
the element where a lot of people don't
realize is when you start a new title
there's like new contracts it's a
different kind of uh it's a business
thing too it is a business thing yeah I
mean by calling it something else but
let's not get into the nitty-gritty of
it but I'm saying like one of the things
that I'm a little bit uh was surprised
is how much animation has become your
thing when did you realize or when did
it happen or did you all of a sudden
awaken to the fact that wait a minute
I'm GNA like animation's the thing I'm
going to be doing this so I moved out
here to do
animation this was like my goal right so
when I first moved to LA um this was
around 2009 2008 2009 I made an Excel
spreadsheet of all the different brands
I dug growing up you know everything
from [__] GI Joe to Voltron
to everything and I was like okay what
is the brand like who owns it who's
optioned it what's going on right
because my goal was to do hard R
takes on these different brands right
I'm like let's do hard r g Jo let's do
hard R Voltron um and I even got a
meeting with Marvel believe it or not
this is before Disney acquired Marvel
right so Marvel was an independent
company there was a guy named uh Eric
rolman who was doing their animated
stuff they partnered with an Indian
company called Tunes to make Wolverine
and the X-Men that ran for like two
seasons and it was like a like I found
out there was a weird contract thing
coming up and I'm like oh my God I can
swoop in there and like do do Age of
Apocalypse you know with with X-Men and
I went in and I was like pitching the
Marvel people and then they were like
how old are
you like who are you how old are what is
he going on
how did you get in here exactly how did
you get this meeting on how did you get
this meeting it was kind of that right
um and U so this was this was always
where I wanted to
land um in in animation not and I didn't
want it to be my only thing but I I
loved animation and part of this is
growing up in uh Hong Kong and Southeast
Asia adult animation is like a thing
it's just a normal thing it's just a
fact of life no one goes adult animation
it's just it's just they don't say
animation sometimes right because it's I
don't think people in America fully
understand the how much animation in
anime is a part of the rest of the world
right so I was confused and then I came
here uh and then when I uh when I spent
time in America in the '90s I was like
obsessed with X-Men the Animated Series
uh and and a and a variety of other
American
cartoons and then as you get a little
older you're like they just
disappear you know what I'm saying like
you're watching Saturday morning
cartoons you're obsessed with them
you're buying the toys you're like
obsessed with the
commercials and then and then all of a
sudden you reach a certain age and then
everyone is supposed to stop watching
cartoons I didn't I didn't get it I'm
like where did they go like I I was
expecting them to age with me yeah not
in America no no it just stops yeah it
just it just stops and then when you
look at the X-Men the Animated Series
they had like uh very adult
oriented very adult oriented story lines
mean you look at the the the pilot KN of
the Sentinels freaking morph dies right
you you you get a main character like
dying in the pilot
of this kids cartoon so it it was
already like laying the the foundation
for for for what came next um and yeah
so to me it was more like why doesn't
this exist and then I happen to just
show up
and and now as you said I'm like
associated with with adult animation
yeah which is listen this is a a a this
is something that I'm I'm happy that
this is being done let's jump into
Captain laserhawk so um one of the
things about this is so let's I have a
lot of questions how did you guys decide
you want it to be six episodes for the
first season or um was it story based
was it budget based like how'd that
number come up a Netflix thing they were
like six great okay you know they they
they kind of just come and they're like
the algorithm
says six I I will say a lot of a lot of
shows now are aiming it used to be 10
then it went to eight and a lot are
going to six yes and um which is fine so
um which is fine it's better six is
better than one no but it's basically
one episode you're you you essentially
made like a two a little over 2hour
movie that's in six parts yeah
essentially so one of the things about
it is you are using a lot of Ubisoft
characters in your show um so my
question is let's talk about going to
Ubisoft and pitching them on what you
wanted to do because it's the first time
that they've agreed to do something
R-rated with their characters yes uh so
what was that process like yeah well I
was already working with Ubisoft
um and you know they' reached out to me
after the the the boot L Universe fan
films um and uh and I had a working
relationship with several of the
executives there and
uh and and look I I I just wrote this up
and sent it to them and they were like
yeah this is great let's do it it didn't
really require a whole lot of convincing
I think if anything there was there was
convincing on the other side to me that
this is real I got it you know what I'm
saying right they're saying yes and
you're like I don't understand cuz like
you know for years you know anytime I
would have like any sort of like hit or
or or even a single or a double you end
up getting Studio meetings sure and you
show up and they're like so what do you
want to do what do you want to do and
I'm like so you have the rights to Waldo
right and they're like yeah uhhuh and
then they all get uncomfortable they're
like what the [__] is he talking about
Waldo I'm like okay so imagine a hard R
where's Waldo it's like born identity
where you know
he's and they're and and you just and
you're like wow this meeting just went
[__] horribly like I should not have
said that out loud so I'm used to I was
used to a lot of those right it's
like sure that that was kind of the the
the like the Rhythm and I'd leave him
like why can't you just pitch something
normal well the thing is though I I
don't a I don't think it's in your DNA
to pitch something normal B it's boring
C it's like that's the vanilla ice cream
that makes no one excited you have to
mix with sprinkles you got to do
something anyway I want to continue so
one of the the character I couldn't
believe was in this with Rayman I just
was like wait what so where did Rayman
come from to put Hitman this series like
where did he come from like no no no not
like his origin but like where the idea
to make him an integral part of this
show when I first had the download about
this show right because because the show
came to me this world came to me I had
uh six images that popped in my head and
one of them was this iteration of Rayman
that you see in the show that was like
one of the the the first kind of images
that flooded into me and that was part
of the pitch it was like and in this
world Rayman is the spokesperson for
this fascist dystopian
uh company that uh is also a nation one
of the things that I I watch a lot of TV
and a lot of movies generally I can I
can picture where everything is going
one of the things I commend you on with
this was it takes a lot of turns that I
did not expect how much was that you you
know what I mean talk a little bit about
that there are constant left and right
turns that the audience will not see
coming yeah I I feel like so you're
you're asking me like how does how did I
come about that and like what's the
process of arriving I mean also just was
it something like it you when you were
coming up with it were you like it has
to take turns the audience does not
expect so my process is is like more
intuitive than it is logical okay if
that makes sense so subconsciously yes
100% I am I am going through that I'm
like I wanted to take twists and turns
but but that that's because I like it
when shows do that right like when I was
younger watching like cont watching
movies all day I didn't like the thing
where all of a sudden okay after the
First Act you know how this is going to
play out right there's a blueprint and
we're just going to follow the formula I
don't I don't like things that are
formulaic which I think intrinsically is
why
um I was subverting IP with the the uh
the like the short the fan films because
there's something about things that are
formulaic
that I don't know how to explain it but
they it makes me really sad right it
kind of De it like I like I feel this
like glimmer of hope die um and and this
isn't just with like movies like even
with video games right like so I loved
uh you know the game kns of the Old
Republic the Star Wars game right it's a
classic I love that game but the
moment I realized oh okay now I get the
formula you're going to go to another
world right and then you're going to
have to collect X X Y and Z items and
then you're going to get back on the
ship and like like once I can see
the the the blueprint behind the
the the the
project I just get a little sad what's
one of the reasons why to be hon I don't
play many video games anymore and one of
the reasons is that for me for me from
the outside they they're all exactly the
same like they're they're not for me
they're not it's I don't want to say
they're all the same cuz people are
going to come at me for that but like
just once you exactly what you said it's
equip this equipment go do this it's
basically built on a structure that's
become very formulaic yes and the games
that i' be interested in are are you
know breaking the mold right you know
and then especially when you look at
like TV and film which you know this is
such an old business such an old
industry so when you look at a genre
like what is a murder mystery right and
you have this deep reservoir of
reference material on what a murder
mystery is and what it should be yeah
and and then there's audience
expectation and what what I find if you
subvert audience expectation too much
there's an element where it just doesn't
work well they need to know like they
ultimately want to be on the train that
they're expecting exact but they are
cool with the individual cars being
radically different than what they were
expecting 1,00% so when you look at a
movie like uh that that that I produced
the voices Ryan Reynolds and a Kendrick
Maran sat tropy who who uh ended up
being a mentor of mine I love Mar kind
of talented very talented yeah that
movie was doing too many different
things I would argue right and then it's
it's what it's it's your train analogy
the audience is like on one train they
like another train another train and
then yeah it it's also when a film or
when anything tries to do too much in
one thing right but moving past all that
uh I want to get back to Captain
laserhawk and um specifically uh I
really enjoyed the aesthetic choices
that were made in telling the story
there are moments where it goes 8 bit
there are moments where it's you know
the animation that you might be
expecting there are other moments where
it's animation you're not expecting
right and it h and it changes very
quickly like it's never too long in one
thing um was that who came up with that
idea to constantly tweak the aesthetic
and you know let's get into that so my
last show guardians of Justice sure uh
was that as well so so you know every
few seconds we're we're shifting
different animation Styles live action
clamation pixel art uh Old School South
Park 2D uh cutout stop motion right and
so I I wanted to do that again with
Captain laser Rock
um and partially because I wanted
Captain laser roock to not just be oh
this is this new world this new universe
and and this dystopian satire but I also
wanted it
visually to be a uh Love Letter to video
games and the advancement of video games
right um but as for the actual choices
that were made like okay now this is
going to be ter not just pixel art but
now this is going to be like an homage
to Platformers this is going to be an
homage an homage to Metal Gear Solid
right like that was 100% all those
decisions were made by uh Bobby pills
the animation studio in the original
drafts of the script we we literally had
it in like okay Dolph goes for a punch
and then it turns into this style and
then and then you cut and then there's
like a it was all baked into the script
and then they were like look dude we get
what you're trying to do we're going to
we love it but let us do it and I'm like
I mean yeah you should absolutely do
this sure so does it I'm curious as a as
a producer um does the aesthetic choice
dictate a budgetary need for example if
you're doing 8bit Graphics versus doing
typical animation is there a difference
in cost or such a difference in cost
that you stylistically can only do
certain choices for a finite amount of
time so for Guardians of justice for
instance and I can speak to that because
you know I I we literally put every
element together and we're sourcing it
from all over the world um you find that
certain
set pieces let's call them set pieces
right uh you can convey like a large
scale destruction in pixel art for a far
cheaper price point than you could in
like Photo realistic CGI I guess what I
said was like super obvious but but
right like I could have given you a
better
example what I'm wondering is that like
because in Captain laser Hawk and and
maybe Bobby pills May
but but but no because here's the thing
like Bobby pills is an animation studio
right so they've got a bunch of like a
team of really talented uh artists from
all over
Europe uh who come in every day to work
on Captain laser hog um so for them it's
more Personnel allocation right so so
the so the cost of making an animated I
I I feel like I've gone off the rails
and how I'm talking about this but but
but there's like a um it's it's
different than when you're doing a
liveaction project and now you need to
go find a vendor to uh deliver you an
asset right so like when when when
Marvel makes like Ant-Man they're then
finding a VFX house to do the VFX shots
sure I no I totally get it I'm because
basically ultimately though no matter
what you're making you have a budget and
so my thing is are creative like how you
know for example like I just spoke to
Matt shakman about the Monarch show
that's Apple TV and I was asking them
I'm like look you can only have the big
Godzilla shots in so many scenes because
those sequences are very expensive yes
so you have to in my opinion you have to
figure out or you know you have to
figure out where do you want Godzilla to
show up in those 10 episodes because you
can only have them show up so many times
so with Captain laserhawk my question is
are there certain things that cost so
much or cost a lot more that that that
you're allocating okay we can only do
this type of animation for 30 minutes of
the 2 hours do you see what I mean I do
see what you mean um I just took a long
way to get that no no no no it it makes
it makes a lot of sense it's it's not
it's it's harder to describe in
animation than it is in live action
right because in live action it's more
obvious you're like okay these
world-ending destruction shots we get
like one of those an episode in in
animation because it's like and and and
especially because Captain laser hwk is
like old school it's handdrawn animation
right it's it's not as uh obvious to
explain
because it's drawn sure you know what I
mean no totally yeah yeah we can move on
to the next thing so the full title is
Captain laserhawk a blood dragon remix
how much did you debate that title did I
personally debate that title well like
I'm curious how the full title came who
came up with it was it almost something
else so I came up with the
title
uh you know yeah I came up with the
title uh the the like if you go back to
the
original like press on it it was
originally like cther laserhawk blood
dragon Vibe it's like blood dragon M but
blood dragon we landed on blood dragon
remix the next thing is when you went to
Ubisoft and and Netflix and they got
involved obviously this is six episodes
how much did Netflix ask you and say hey
we want to make sure you have like a
three season plan if this were to be a
hit or is it based on your track record
already they're like we we trust you
let's just make this one season it it
wasn't the first thing you described
right it wasn't like we need to know who
the big bad is of season 3 it was it
wasn't the your typical like kind of TV
speak it was more hey we trust you sure
but there was also an element of hey we
trust you we don't fully get what you're
doing so it was like it was like does
that make sense it was like it it was
like a little bit of skepticism I'm not
saying they weren't supportive I mean
like again Netflix has been like The
Ultimate Gift to to me creatively in my
creative process and they've you know
let me
do things and get away with things that
uh no you know what I mean I listen I I
really appreciate that Netflix is making
animation like this and doing things
that are not vanilla ice cream right you
know but I think there was a not I think
I there was so much of this show that
was in my head that was super obvious to
me right but they had no idea but but
but not not just they like no one no one
like to to like does that make sense
because the show in a way is so tonally
specific it is so it's such a specific
show that when things are obvious to you
you don't necessarily understand that
other people may not have the reference
point and they're not seeing what you're
seeing so it forces you to get really
specific in your language sure my my
thing is how long did it actually take
once Netflix said okay we're going to
make this right how long was it from
them saying yes to it actually getting
on the air was it three years was it two
years was it what was that number so
technically they said yes in 20 uh 20
okay so technically they said yes like
uh like actually right after the the
pandemic but they also said yes before
that I just there was some process that
had to happen like you know deals that
to be oh no Clos so I didn't take it
seriously because I don't take you know
because I look the whole time with this
project I'm just like yeah okay I kept
waiting for someone to like an adult to
show up and be like you you stop stop
you're doing it again this thing that
you do you create chaos you're doing it
again but here's my thing so they say
yes and you you build the infrastructure
you work with other people you get the
show on the air right you make the six
episodes say people tune in right how
quickly can you know and maybe it's
possible you guys are working on other
episodes that I don't know about but my
question is if the show is a hit and
Netflix says we want more how quickly
can more episodes be made do you think
the show will be ahead I can't predict
anything anymore
but I will say that I I really don't
know because the thing with Netflix is I
love them because they make so much but
sometimes it's hard to find their
content so I just don't know like let's
use an example Wes Anderson has four
short films that just came out right on
Netflix no one is talking about them no
one and this is Wes Anderson with like
four or five short films right so what
do I know I I would recommend Captain
laser Hawk uh but I don't know
if I'm a crazy you know what I mean like
but but you have always I mean I
remember going karaoke singing with you
uh New York Comic Con the year was
201 that was going to say a very long or
2014 and you turned to me and you said
this movie John Wick it's going to blow
up sure have you seen it I'm like yeah
yeah I met with Chad and Dave I I I know
them but like I'm like yeah it'll it'll
do well I mean they're talented action
guys and you're like no no no no no no
no no no no no this is going to redefine
how action movies get made for the next
10 years you literally said that to me
right so what one of the things I'm
curious about is you basically have evil
Power Rangers yes in Captain laser
completely so where that and I play one
of them yeah well we're about to get
into that but we can talk about it now
you are the red I am the Red Power
Ranger yes so let's talk about why you
decided to be the red one and maybe
because he has the most lines and B um
where the idea for the power evil Power
Rangers come from so you
know such a load of question because you
know i' I've worked on Power Rangers
before you know and an unauthorized sure
uh capacity you know so the Rainbow Six
were originally in it it was always like
the Rainbow Six because Rainbow Six
Siege is a big Ubisoft property Ubisoft
actually has a lot of Tom Clancy uh uh
branded Gams right
um
yeah actually Alex lson and I Alex
Larson is one of the writers uh on the
show um we were we were talking one day
and and and this came about because of a
like a like like me and him were riffing
that's how it came about we were like we
were like riffing he's great because he
was like dude like you know this is a
fun nod to your your work on Power
Rangers and the thing and you you
clearly love
this you
know and I I wanted like Megazords and
that kind of vibe in the show right and
then it just it just fit perfectly what
are you actually most excited for people
to see in the show I know it's a generic
question but I'm I'm sincere with it in
a way it's not like just one thing
because it's it's it's really the it's
what you were alluding to in the
beginning it's all the twists and turns
right because I've I've spent the last
10 years really studying all the subg
genres that we are either spoofing
satirizing or riffing on and I've I've
like really you know I I mentioned this
earlier in the the uh before the
interview started like I've been dealing
with like some crazy chronic illness
issues um that nearly killed me so and I
I just basically I went from being this
like super
extroverted dude who was like crushing
it in the in the Hollywood ecosystem and
I got like you know got to go to cool
events and cool parties to the point
where like I couldn't leave my house cuz
I was like constantly uh overstimulated
and didn't really understand what was
going on and couldn't articulate what
was going on so I so I spent a lot of
time um really going okay what am I
going to do with this time now because
I'm effectively a
gorob and I just really studied genre
sub genre writing
screenplays and I did a deep dive on
this
stuff so um so yeah I think it's the
it's the subverting of
expectations is what I'm excited for
people to watch um and because I feel
like people our age and younger watch a
lot more things than people older than
us right because they have less access
to to to stuff like you you you go to
the movie three four times a year you
you have a couple DVDs that you watch
and repeat and and TV shows and that's
it I I feel like people now have a like
like a more Baseline understanding of
the of the tropes sure right so yeah
uh you know and and and like with the
show I really wanted to feel like um
like like what is what does like a
Prestige TV dystopian satire look like
okay now let's do the wacky cartoon
version of that you know what I'm saying
sure CU there's like
a cuz on some level you could totally
see the man on a high castle like super
serious it's supposed to be an hour long
but we're actually going to spend 75
minutes per episode uh like really dark
HBO style take of this this
world right you could totally do it yeah
you could totally do it absolutely but I
wanted to take that and go 22
minutes in a
wacky cartoon and using that to kind of
uh not necessarily subvert subvert is
the wrong word but like I I I hope
broaden it hope broaden the message
right to make it more accessible sure
because I'm using the language of sorry
I want to use the language of like anime
animation cartoons Saturday morning
cartoons and just amalgamate all of it
because you know the other thing that
you'll notice you will have noticed
having watched the show is it's not just
that the show exists in multiple uh
animation mediums but even the
characters within the
show they have different art styles
absolutely and that's one of the things
I dug about it is that it it's
everything's unexpected as it as it goes
out right you know but the the reason
the the characters have different art
styles is I I really wanted this to feel
like a crossover show like these are you
know different these are characters from
different worlds and they're coming
together and so instead of having like
one
consistent uh art style for the whole
thing when you look at a character like
bullfrog right and then you compare them
to Alex like they're from different
shows different worlds so to speak 100%
I need to switch to another subject
because I'm going to be running out of
time right and uh so I definitely want
to talk about Devil May Cry so when can
fans expect to perhaps see this on the
Netflix uh it's uh dropping tomorrow
devil make rry yeah no I was going to be
like what no there's no chance it's true
it's no chance it's true yeah maybe next
week okay so being serious uh it's next
year it may be next year okay so you I'm
not going to get that information how
can you say how many episodes it is in
the first season less than 20 got it
okay another avoid good job um where are
you in the production of the show in
terms of like it was it a really early
Announcement by Netflix to say to show
that little tease or is it one of these
things where you guys are like you're
you're into it like emotionally
emotionally I'm into it no as in the
physical production of said TV
show well it's animation so we're not
actually physically making it it's like
drawing um how much are you allowed to
not say about the show I did get an
email saying hey Addie uh when you're
talking about Las please don't talk
about double M cry oh should we like
like for real avoid it or yeah I think
so although I think this funny
Rift but yeah I did I did actually we
can keep this in too sure it's fine I
did get an email I it didn't get sent to
me it got you know sent to someone else
and then I got a call actually literally
last night saying hey Chill on the DMC
stuff what's funny is what people might
not realize is how this is not like an
isolated thing this like I know a lot of
people who I do interviews with and
they'll tell me hey just to let you know
I really you know I have a cannot talk
about said project I think it's a good
sign though when you get an email or or
or people tell you not to talk about it
because you know you know what I'm
saying that's a good sign versus yeah
just say whatever you want well it also
comes down to like because one of the
things about Netflix is they really
don't like having things that are coming
out like they like to really like
promote something when it's about to
come out yes so like a Devil May Cry and
I really don't know if it's a year away
they don't want people talking about it
like right like they want people to know
what's coming that's about it yes yes
and I was I was there when that just
when that realization got made I I don't
mean with devil MC cry I mean just in
general right because I've been working
with Netflix now basically since 2015
yeah yeah it was it was around 2017
where uh one of my favorite execs there
was like telling me ex what you said
it's like you want to harness the power
of the internet for the shows coming out
right I couldn't tell you what Netflix
has coming out next year even though I
know some of them because they are so
adverse to like pushing next year it's
always about what's right in front of
you yeah and I I feel like that they
they understand internet internet
culture better than like maybe some of
the the Legacy St to that regard because
I feel like some of
the some movies get spoiled because you
see the trailer and then you're like oh
now I know the whole movie before yeah
that listen that the trailer culture
makes me insane because um the the the
problem and I I keep saying it but I'll
just say it to you is that trailers are
designed movie trailers are designed for
people that go to the movies like two
times a year and you're trying to entice
those those people to why should this be
the movie they go to see you give them a
lot and but it's not designed for you
and me who watch trailers cuz we will
put the entire film together dude you
like dissect it yes Infinity war and
endgame did a great job of this because
you you have these trailers and they
were all MDS yeah there was still
footage in there like my my I say this
to everyone if you're going to go see a
movie then don't watch the trailer cuz
you're going to have a much better
experience if you've not seen footage
the problem is it's hard to not watch
cuz you want to see it right so it's
like you know avoid the drug and then
anyway um so let's switch to something
maybe you can't talk about you are what
other things are you currently working
on that you're allowed to say or are you
working on a lot of things that you're
not allowed to talk about I'm working on
a lot of things that either I'm not
allowed to talk about or there's not
context for me to talk about it does
that make sense where if I if I tell you
like for instance I'm uh creative
directing a video game
which and it's a it's a it's not an
original game it's like based on a a
gaming IP that everybody knows so this
is something that you're how long have
you been working on it a year and well
arguably longer but really just so
you're putting your spin on the video
game yeah is it something that will be
out next year or still it's far away
yeah video games are are like a thing
man it's like a it's like a it's a
process well it also depends on how big
is the budget on the game because if
it's a small game it could be a year or
two but if it's a big game I mean that
could be five years yeah exactly so
we're years away yeah
also and also dealing with the looming
threat of like plugs can be pulled on
things like at any moment oh by the way
like especially given that we're like in
this financial meltdown that is
happening within the uh apparatus that
governs what gets made and what doesn't
get made oh hi I mean I can name so many
filmmakers I know who a week before they
were scheduled to shoot you know
financing pulled out that was or or or
Sam Ismail right you think Mr Robot dude
like his uh his Metropolis show the plug
got pulled on it like after been working
on it for seven years you're like dude
like how do you recover from that
emotionally or guo with The Hobbit years
right you know like I mean but I feel
like guo is like a boss here where he he
constantly has like seven people
courting him sure but the problem is
like I just did a long interview with
him and the problem is like he worked on
that Star Wars movie and then it didn't
get made he worked on at the mountains
of Madness Tom Cruz didn't get made he
is he has 30 scripts he's made 12 I
think he said he has 30 unproduced
Scripts
out of like the 10 that he's made or the
12 that he's made do you feel like GMO
would like Captain L Rock yes I do think
GMO would like Captain L Rock feel like
he like but he also loves animation so I
think anything animation but that's a
whole separate thing um maybe I'll send
him a link perhaps yeah perhaps so
basically you can't really say other
things you're working on are you working
on any other animated projects yes I am
working on other animated projects that
is correct yeah are they all at Netflix
or are they o over at different places
and are there more than three I'm me
courted by other places that's
interesting that's a new that's a nice
feeling it's different than I would
because there's like a sadness to uh
Executives now in Hollywood yeah look I
think the last because you we we we've
we've I mean I've been doing this for
sure for for a while right there's you
know post uh uh the streaming Wars the
strikes me to movement
uh the economic shifts
it feels like there's a lot
of well one job insecurity but also just
like sadness within the ecosystem it's a
very unstable time right it's an
unstable time and and like you know when
I started in this business everyone
assumed that they were what they were
doing was or at least it felt that way
it felt like everyone assumed that what
they were doing was the most important
thing in the
world right like oh my God we've got
this movie coming out it is the most
important thing it's going to change the
world and now it's
like what whatever that delusion
was I feel like it was helpful because
it created like an optimism within the
the uh the apparatus and the ecosystem
that is is entertainment that is gone
that is gone it it just feels like
Despair and sadness I'm not and I'm not
like that I'm like happy and running
around I'm like yeah I got to make stuff
but yeah there is like
a like a like a sadness and Netflix has
been
wonderful I this is this isn't a Netflix
thing because they're they're in their
own sure I know people that are making
stuff at Netflix and they're also making
stuff at Apple and other places exactly
the same time yeah it's it's not like
you don't have to have a marriage to
just one company right right no but I'm
but I'm saying like in Netflix has been
in the time that I've been working with
them very internationally minded right
so it's not it's not like an LA based no
company they're very listen I mean
they're and think about what they done
with South Korean content and blown it
out around the world and also I don't
think people realize you like for
example with Captain laserhawk say it
doesn't do well in America but it's the
number one show in Asia that's enough to
keep it on the air exactly you know
exactly they have 84 countries yeah
they're programming for the world yes
where it felt like when I first moved
here movies were programming for
Hollywood right you're trying to like
look cool in Hollywood yeah and yeah
listen that's one of the reasons why
anytime I speak or read or see people
talking about box office if you're not
talking about the global numbers you
like or at least bringing it into the
conversation so say a movie makes $10
million in America but it made a 100
million globally you need to tell the
audience well it didn't do well in
America but globally it made $100
million well this is how I this is how
it broke in right I was I was uh working
in the international foreign
sales uh
distribution arm of of the movie
business where where you realize like oh
you know it used to be like 90% of the
the the revenue from a movie came from
the US then it became like 30% and 70%
came from International yep and uh you
know obviously comedy there are
exceptions things like comedies uh
dramas but for like the genre that I
exist in action
movies uh action thr rers sci-fi like
7030 listen uh and sometimes it's 90%
America 10% Global and sometimes it's
10% America 90% Global you have to think
with the global audience which is why
it's so important to always talk about
global numbers but um on that note uh
I'm just going to say I really do hope
sincerely that the show is a huge hit
for you and I'd love to see more stuff
like this that is not vanilla ice cream
thank you thank you I uh I really
appreciate that man like this the the
whole I'm so grateful to
Ubisoft cuz I in a way I've like glossed
over this as we've been talking like I'm
like yeah they said yes and but it was
more than just saying yes it was like
saying yes and then Paving the
road right like just Paving the road
because you know even even a little
thing like when you go out to pitch the
show so I go out and I have like Network
meetings you know pitching it here
pitching it there and you're with the
head of the network they're kind of like
come on dude they're not going to let
you do this right so one of the one of
the owners of one of the brothers that
owns Ubisoft Gerard he actually came to
the pitch meetings oh yeah right like
which that was like super meaningful
like I don't know I just felt really I
was like wow I feel really supported I
feel really seen you know what I mean
but also I'm sure he's very like uh
excited about what this could also do
for some of the characters you know what
I mean it's thinking of like listen
they're obviously very smart to think
outside the box because van again I keep
on going back to vanilla ice cream but I
don't want to see vanilla ice cream I
want to see stuff that's different you
know and at least they're smart enough
to do something different yeah and then
obviously
um I I don't know what vanilla ice cream
looks like I literally start at [__]
an amalgamation of rainbow and no but
listen listen but it's the same it's the
same thing with um I put on panels at
comic-com it's the same thing with me
like the reason my panels are good is
because I don't have Studios telling me
let's just do this you know what I mean
I just th anyway uh I got to stop so I'm
just going to say thank you for this and
like I said I really do hope it's a huge
hit bro I [__] love you okay I'll
take you're like my spirit animal
dude